ah yes this next performer
she really lights up the banana more
stage
hey everyone so good to be here um i
can't believe i'm doing stand-up comedy
again because i was quarantined with my
family for
six months don't recommend that oh man
i just i'm glad that 2020 is finally
over okay that was a crazy year
um we had the pandemic we had protests
taylor swift released two albums it was
nuts nobody saw that coming
but my favorite thing that happened in
2020 was uh there was this giant
wildfire that was started by a gender
reveal party
i don't if you guys remember the story
uh and i read all the articles about it
and i got
so mad because i
still don't know what gender the baby is
yeah i'm like wasn't that the whole
point of the party you're like i don't
care how many acres of land you burn
down
is it a boy or is it a girl let me know
yeah turns out the gender was fire so
it's also what this gender is i did get
a haircut recently finally
um that was the toughest part about the
pandemic for me was i couldn't get a
haircut for months
and my hair was getting so long that i
didn't even look gay anymore yeah i was
like showing up to these zoo meetings
and people are like
who's that straight girl and i'm like oh
this is a problem
there's a reason my hair looks like this
it's for women
so yeah i actually had to spend uh my
second birthday uh on zoom this year uh
have you guys been to a zoom party
they're terrible okay
like have you guys had 10 people saying
happy birthday to you
not at the same time yeah you can hear
individually how bad of a singer
everyone is but the worst part is you
can't really
leave the zoom there's no good excuse
like back when we went to real life
parties
you could just be like hey man great
party uh where's the bathroom
and then you just go home right but on
zoom you can't be like
hey um i gotta go to another room in my
house
yeah i'd rather stare at my wall than be
here
with you so i'm just gonna pretend my
wi-fi stopped working next time i think
that's the only way to get out of it
i will say at this point uh it's been a
year that we've been inside
if your ex has not reached out to you
you've never been in love
okay like we've all talked to our exes
at this point
just to check up on them you know i just
want to make sure that
i'm doing better than you yeah i don't
want you be doing bad
just like worse than me all right
thank you guys so much i've been irene
[Applause]
too